MOST PROBLEMS FOR THE DUCKSKS,
LITTLE BIT OF SPACE FOR Y YIT W
OUT OF PLAY NEVER MADE IT TO
.
NOW THE WHISTLE AND A PENALTY
COMING UP AGAINST THEROL.
>> DON'T DUMP IT IN IF YOU DON'
HAVE T TGO PER TRIES TO GO
HIGHER SHORT SIDE.
HE STAYED ON HIS FEET AND MADE
EACH AND EVERY TIME...
ANDERS LEE BROKEN UP.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT HIM AT THE
TOP OF THE BROADCAST.
HE GOT A NICE LITTLE PASS BACK
FROM
PARISE, THE LEFT SHOT TO P P PA
DOWN OFF THE LEFT TOWARDS BY
THEY CAN THANK ANTHONY FOR THAT.
THE ISLANDERS S S PERIMETER, BU
HE PLAYED FOR THE RED ARMY TEAM
THERE. GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT.SIM.
HE IS FU.
ZEGRAS HOLDS IT AS LONG AS HE
CAN.
BEHIND THE NET,
HITS THE BRAKE-0 THANKS
JOHNSTON, THE LOAN FORWARD THAT
BACK.
40 FEET OUT OF HIS NET TO PLAY
THE PUCKCKD THE CORNER.CHANCE.
THAT PUCK WAS SITTING THERE AND
HAND YOU HAVE.
IT'S GOING TO BE NIGHTS WHERE